my name is Adam Savage welcome to the
Star Trek beyond fan event tonight we
are going to yes we are going to boldly
go where no one has gone before
you might not know it but right now we
are in a piece of history we are
standing in the middle of stage 31 and
this is one of the stages they filmed
the original series of Star Trek on for
me personally the first time I saw a
kiss on television the woman was green I
don't know what I was learning from
Captain Kirk it probably wasn't great
but that show formed me the early 70s it
was on constantly and I absolutely is a
key part of the person that I ended up
becoming this year marks the 50th
anniversary of Star Trek let us get
right into it there's no need to delay
anymore let's bring out the producer of
Star Trek ladies and gentlemen JJ Abrams
I can just I want to say one thing first
of all first of all thank you all for
coming out but mostly your seats are so
much more comfortable than these but to
be here with everyone is a is a real
thrill to be talking about the 50th
anniversary is insane I was born the
same year that Star Trek was I know how
old I feel so the idea that you know
this thing indoors is incredible and a
real honor to be part of it to be
totally honest I've said this since the
you know the 2009 movie I was not a Star
Trek fan as a kid and I realized what I
missed out on because I got to fall in
love with it watching the shows when I
started working on the film and Justin
Lin who is an extraordinary guy and a
wonderful director and he did an amazing
job on this he was a Star Trek fan from
I think the very very beginning I mean
he would he would watch with his parents
and everything and he loved and knew
this world so well and he was really
inspiring to talk to and I just felt
that this was someone who unlike myself
loved it from the beginning and though I
fell in love with it later I feel like
this is you know we were so lucky all of
us to get to work with Justin on this
movie shall we bring Justin out yes what
do you think all right
ladies and gentlemen let's bring out
Justin Lin the director of Star Trek
beyond I think that's part of Star Trek
you know I think it's a shared journey
with with with these characters with
this great crew but at the same time
you're pushing into unknown you know you
I think that's that's what I love about
is embracing stuff you know with these
characters that's been you've been known
for 50 years but at the same time or a
constantly pushing and and and
challenging ourselves I think you have
to embrace it you know I think that's
what makes it great and you know I think
what JJ is done so great is that we can
celebrate embrace everything that's
that's that in the last 50 years but at
same time we have these great characters
are going into these new adventures and
they're gonna make choices and they're
gonna face challenges and they're gonna
keep evolving and growing getting beamed
up I think that was always the thing
when I was a little kid you know and so
I remember stepping into the hallways of
enterprising and the lights weren't on
they're still like painting it and stuff
and just walking in there and feeling
like wow I'm now part of this and
they're asking like what color of white
you want that wall to be those moments
are definitely you know something that I
think everybody cares and then we have a
great group of people the cast is
amazing you know I got the all-star team
to come and it's it's been a dream come
true
and some great new additions obviously
to means anything can happen you know I
think that's what's so fun about being a
part of this is that you know these
characters and themes and we can go
anywhere and and we can evolve and they
can bigger they're gonna run into new
challenges and and and nothing should
there should be no boundaries few months
back there was a fan movie Axanar that
was getting made and there was this like
lawsuit that happened between the studio
and these fans and Justin and I need to
tell the story because he probably
wouldn't was sort of outraged by this as
a longtime fan and we started talking
about it realized that this was not you
know an appropriate way to deal with the
fans the fans should be celebrating this
thing like you're saying right now we
all fans of Star Trek are part of this
world and so
you went to the studio and pushed them
to stop this lawsuit and now within the
next few weeks it will be announced this
is going away and fans will be able to
work on their projects
well we're partnering with comic-con and
we're gonna do our premiere in San Diego
on July 20th it's gonna be I believe the
first time ever imax outdoor no way
we're gonna have a live orchestra
Michael chiquinho is gonna be conducting
would you guys like to meet some stars
from the movie I thought you might okay
so right now please join me in welcoming
Chris Pine Zachary Quinto and Karl Urban
I think it's great you know the first
couple of films were really about at
least four for Kirk his relationship
with Spock and and in that pairing and
in this film these two definitely get a
chance to suss out their relationship
and I get to tour the galaxy with the
little Anton I want to play evil Kirk in
a bad bad way
yeah and may I have a little bones in me
I think and the most fun I have on this
film is having fun and I think this the
tone of this film was definitely in the
vein of what we did in the first which
was kind of fun pop which has great
pathos and a great storyline some great
action but we we like to have fun it's
not the super broad of the Marvel it's
not meta it's just fun yeah and that's
why we all like to make each other laugh
it was Simon bond you know with his pen
in the background giving us some good
zingers and whatnot we had a blast and I
think you'll see that in this film I
think it's one of the wonderful things
about what we do in this picture is not
only are we honoring the legacy of all
the fantastic Star Trek that has been
before but we're actually exploring new
territory and this one's gonna make it
so exciting the fact that that bones and
Spock get to spend so much time together
and come to a deeper understanding as it
were I think there's gonna be a real
treasure for an audience I think for me
the
the cool thing about us making this
picture in Vancouver the other two
pictures we shot here in Los Angeles and
look la-based cast had their social
networks but this was like a fraternity
we were all were staying out we're
forced get over your big guy so I feel
like we we all grew a lot closer and
became tighter as a group and I think
they are you gonna see that on screen
well yes he finds himself crash-landed
on a planet with Spock I mean talk about
a nightmare scenario yeah I kind of like
on wait 41 needs to see this is so much
fun these are two characters who are
historically pretty diametrically
opposed so you know there's I think also
a lot of humor that comes from that and
a lot of like Carl said a lot of a lot
of death and and and I think they really
do finish this film with a deeper
appreciation from one another than when
they started it I mean I think they were
always friends in a way I just think
they approach things from very different
points of view and express things very
differently but I think I think the
relationship benefited from the lack of
buffer and the fact that ultimately they
really need each other in just in order
to survive you know and and the whole
movie really is about all of us finding
our way back to one another and and and
understanding the power of of when we
unify when we're together and and I
think for these two characters for
audiences who know them and love them
and his arrest ability and you know
Spock's calculated point of view I think
it's going to be really exciting and
anyway oh yeah sorry so yeah I think I
think it's cool what's nice about our
relationship is that there's a parody
there that two people that are in the
same kind of boat and coming from a
similar spot and with hemp Don in this
film he anton has in check off there's a
clarity to him he likes his job he likes
he likes the group he's with and he's
not kind of encumbered by the same
yes that the rest of us are and I
there's some there's some very there's
there's a buddy comedy aspect to what we
end up doing that I think people will
enjoy hands down my favorite part of
filming these movies is getting to spend
all my time with these people who are
incredible and you know it keeps being
brought up that we've been doing this
for almost 10 years which is kind of
unfathomable but it was 2007 when we
made the first movie and and it just you
know we are truly a family to one
another and even though we only get to
work together every few years we stay in
touch and we stay connected and and
these are people that will be in my life
for the rest of it and and that to me is
is easily the best part about about the
experience so different you know this is
a different film for Kirk the first two
films I think we're really about him
dealing with the shadow of his father
you know he was born on the day that his
father died and that cast a looming
looming amount of pressure on him to
live up to something and the something
was something that in someone he didn't
really know so the pressure was almost
unbearable I think and in this one I
think he's turned a corner and he's
realizing now as a man who's dealt with
those issues with who is he has his own
man and what does it like to be the
captain of a starship and to captain
these people without without needing to
burden himself with that legacy and in
that new space that there's a lot of
freedom there and thinking about what
does he really want to do what really
will make him happy and and then the
drama ensues and stuff happens but that
bad I think is where you find Kirk in
the beginning of this film and I think
Spock is similarly trying to figure out
his path I mean as everybody remembers
from the first film of our reboot you
know his planet was destroyed and and I
think he's really torn between his
allegiance to rebuilding his race and
his allegiance to the Federation and
Starfleet and and I think that Kirk and
Spock rely on each other a lot for
guidance through those tough moments
they don't really necessarily have that
in this film so they they both I think
arrive at an understanding of who they
as individuals in an interesting way
because they're not together they don't
have each other to rely on the first
film for me was it was quite terrifying
because you know I'm a long-term fan of
Star Trek I watched it growing up as a
kid and and then when JJ cast me in the
movie I felt that if I wasn't in the
movie and I was going to the cinema I
would want to see something that some
recognizable semblance of the character
that I grew up in love and I think that
in some way for all of us that was a
challenge was to identify what the the
very essence of those characters were
and were done so brilliantly well bye
bye bye the the the original actors for
40 odd years - originally I were to
identify what their essence is and then
distill it into a younger version of
that character and make it our own and
there were some days where it was quite
nerve-wracking but I think we were all
blessed by the fact that we had such a
wonderful helmsman and helmsman in the
face of Abrams yeah I mean it's
definitely anytime you're on the bridge
of the enterprise and there's 50 million
buttons you cannot help but go and push
every single one of them just to see if
something's gonna happen I've been
getting that question a lot actually
what was it like to make this the first
movie without Leonard and in a way I
feel like he's actually almost more a
part of this film than he was of the
other two I mean we all were so
cognizant of his absence but I think in
the face of that we all held him in our
heart so much more fully and and I think
to the person on this film everybody
showed up to work in the spirit of
celebrating his life and his indelible
contribution to this franchise because
honestly I don't really see how it could
have lasted as long as it did without
him both as an actor and as a director
oh yeah I mean obviously obviously it
comes with a lot of sadness and and we
all miss him all the time but uh but I
feel like you know you'll see he's he's
there he's there in a really powerful
way and now we're going to ask you guys
to participate with us in a really
special moment in honoring Leonard Nimoy
in a few minutes we're gonna ask you to
walk down through this tunnel and sit on
the bleachers outdoors to the left where
you will participate with us and the
Nimoy family in a naming ceremony of the
street out there in honor of Leonard
Nimoy's incredible contribution to one
of the most iconic characters in film
and television I will see you guys all
outside I think it would be appropriate
if you said a few words on this in Los
Angeles and striving to be an actor for
a lot of years before I landed the roles
that have you here in the company of
these amazing people and many times was
I on this lot looking at the map to try
to figure out what office I needed to be
in in order to audition for whatever
show I was auditioning for movie I was
auditioning for at the time and and you
know this studio is built on its own
history and the buildings and the
streets here reflect that and and they
were always my kind of beacons and they
would be none of their might be things
to find my way to the casting directors
but they were also my beacons of like
where I came from and where I wanted to
go and so to be here now is such an
honor and on top of that I would say
when I got this role I never imagined
how my life would change not only
because of the creative experience but
even more because of the personal
experience and the relationship that I
forged with Leonard and the relationship
that be fostered and nurtured in the
last eight years of his life
I was so fortunate enough to be a part
of it and now that he's gone I feel even
more grateful that that relationship has
led me to my relationship with this
family and I love them like my own and
they've been so incredible and carry on
his spirit in such beautiful ways and if
they are so wonderful and they're all
here tonight so many of them here
tonight his wife Susan and it really is
this is I don't know this is just such
an incredible moment because I know that
so many other young actors in the future
are going to be stumbling their way
around this lot and Leonard will guide
them in the way that he guided me and
I'm going to do that because we are
about to unveil and it is a great honor
than my privilege to officially open at
Paramount Studios Leonard Nimoy way so
let's raise a glass and hold it in our
hearts
yeah I already chose I said raising on
it all right
they did you guys are all witnessing a
little bit of history right here and you
are now going to be part of the
historical record of that if you all
look up at the scissor lift you can't
see pass the lights here we're taking a
photo commemorating it so everyone look
up and say me one
you